we've been using Samsung's s24 Ultra for
a week now and so far it is a great
phone but our partner Oppo wanted to
send us the find X7 Ultra and it looks
absolutely incredible in terms of the
specs looks very promising so in this
video we're going to be comparing it to
see just how well it Stacks up to the
s24 ultra by comparing everything from
the designs the speakers and especially
the cameras because this thing has an
insane camera system so let's go ahead
and get this thing unboxed ooh that's a
tight tight
fit all right let's get this thing out
and oh look at that that's
interesting wow look at this it's got
this really nice vegan leather feels
super nice and smooth especially when
you're holding it like this nice grip
but dang look at that design this is way
different a lot of phones these days
look like this the s 24 Ultra where you
have glass you have the camera bumps
really nice and simple but this thing is
all out look at this massive camera ring
right on top with these cameras that
just stick out at you like Matt I really
like this kind of glossy design aspect
here plus the leather this is definitely
unique from what you usually see in
terms of the camera bumps you can see
that the s24 ultra has this really
simple clean layout
but the Oppo just goes crazy this
massive I think they call it the cosmos
camera ring sticks out like crazy which
probably means it's going to have some
good cameras on the inside I believe
this is Hassel blad and it almost looks
like you could spin this thing with all
these little ridges on the side it
definitely looks cool and look at this
right on top the Oppo actually has an
additional speaker Grill which the s24
for Ultra doesn't have you could see
another speaker Grill here on the bottom
and you also get that little Notch at
the top of the display so it has
multiple speaker grills which sounds
pretty promising in terms of the button
layout it's pretty similar here you have
the power button the volume rockers but
the Oppo also has this mechanical little
ringer switch oh man that's already
quite fun to play with and of course
they both have USBC on the bottom with
the little SIM tray but the s20 for
Ultra comes with that S Pen which is
pretty cool and while I'm setting this
up I do want to mention that the Oppo
does come with a charging brake in the
box which the s24 ultra doesn't but this
is not your regular charging brake
because it supports 100 watt fast
charging which will charge from 0 to
100% in 26 minutes which is literally
insane not only that but the Oppa also
supports 50 W wireless charging compared
to 15 on the s24 ultra this thing's the
beast in terms of charging and now
moving over to the front I definitely
like how the Oppo feels in the hand it's
got the rounded edges all the way around
so it feels really nice and smooth and
these Corners are also rounded so they
feel nice in your palm whereas the s24
ultra kind of digs in cuz it has these
like super sharp boxy Corners so
definitely feels nicer for the Oppo and
as far as the display they both look
really good they both have the really
minimal whole punch cameras but I do
think that the bezels are a little bit
thinner potentially on the s24 ultra so
they look nice and uniform compared to
the Oppo which looks like it has a
little bit thicker bezels but still
looks nice and clean especially because
of the curved glass which makes it look
thinner on the sides and has a really
cool effect and I really love how they
make the speaker Grill at the top of the
bezel look basically invisible like you
have to look so close to see it but but
with that said let's do a speaker
quality
[Music]
comparison now I don't know about you
guys but to me it sounds like the
Samsung is a little bit louder but it
sounds like they're pushing up the
vocals too high while the Oppo does
sound a little bit more natural and I
think the Oppo does have a little bit
more base more Punchy base as well so
overall they're fairly similar now in
terms of the actual OS the speed the
snappiness I'd say that both of them
feel very very smooth we have color
ossos on the Oppo which is really nice I
like a lot of the new features
especially like the file dock which
works really well I actually made a full
video on it showing off the new AI
features and I really like it so if you
want to check it out definitely watch
that video after this one's over and now
with that said let's get into the
display quality now interestingly both
of these have 6.8 in displays and both
also have 1440p resolution which works
while at the maximum 120 HZ refresh rate
which is really nice and why this feels
so smooth on both of these I would say
that I really like how the colors pop on
the Oppo especially with their new Pro
xdr display which does have Dolby vision
support which is awesome the s24 ultra
does not support that now in terms of
the actual display brightness the Oppo
does go up to 4500 nits local Peak
versus 2600 on the s24 ultra which
actually does work outside at that
brightness while the Oppo just goes up
to 1,600 nits outside but if I manually
turn them up all the way like this
turning on high performance mode with
maximum display brightness they look
very similar I think the s24 ultra is a
little bit bright brighter here to me
but if I start to turn it and look at it
from the side I think the viewing angles
on the Oppo actually are better now in
terms of HDR video playback in YouTube
you guys can see that they both look
practically identical in some areas the
Oppo actually looks a little bit
brighter but the colors look great and I
almost have to say that I like the
contrast and the pop a little bit better
on the Oppo another difference I do
notice is that the Samsung does have
better antireflectivity Coatings so I'm
seeing less kind of Gray from the
ceiling tiles showing up on the display
so it looks kind of more black has
deeper blacks but the Oppo does have the
better viewing angles and still looks
really good moving on to the performance
they both actually have the same
Snapdragon 8 gen 3 which is awesome but
the Oppo does come with 16 gigs of RAM
compared to 12 on the bass s24 Ultra so
you should get probably a little bit
better multitasking with the Oppo and
now let's get into the biggest part of
this comparison and this video which is
the camera comparison now Oppo has a new
hypertone camera system which has the
first ever quad main camera system which
basically has four rear cameras all with
50 megapixel sensors which is very
impressive you have the 0.6x ultra wide
the 1X main the 3x telephoto which is a
periscope and another 6X telephoto
Periscope basically the first phone in
the world that has two periscopes and it
basically covers the full range of Zoom
lengths with Optical lenses similar to
the s24 ultra which instead of the 6X it
just has a 5x Optical on the high-end
now instead of going for cameras with 50
megapixels the s20 4 ultra takes a
different route with 200 megapixels on
the 1X main camera a 12 megapix Ultra
wide a 10 megapixel 3x Zoom which is a
much smaller sensor than what you get in
the Oppo with the 50 megapixel and then
finally they have the 50 megapixel 5x
Periscope on the s24 ultra and then on
the front cameras the s24 has only a 12
megapixel selfie cam while you get 32
megapixels with the Oppo starting off by
comparing the selfie cameras you can see
just how much the extra 32 megapixel
resolution helps on the Oppo leading to
higher sharpness and more detail and
then moving on to the main cameras the
Oppa uses Sony's brand new second gen
1in sensor yes 1 in the light 900 which
is really really impressive it's very
efficient and look looking at the
Quality you can see just how much more
natural bokeh you get in the background
looking more like a professional DSLR
camera and even compared to the 200
megapixel sensor in the s24 ultra the
Oppo looks better because it's actually
over 60% bigger in terms of the sensor
which will make low light photography a
lot cleaner with less noise now moving
on to the ultra wide camera the Oppo
looks really sharp and detailed because
of the 50 megapixel resolution sensor
compared to just 12 on the Samsung and
not only that but it actually has a
faster f2.0 aperture compared to f2.2
which does help in low light as well so
it's definitely the clear winner but the
biggest difference of all is going to be
the 3x telephoto camera which is
actually a periscope on the find X7
Ultra coming with a 50 megapixel sensor
that's actually actually 300% larger
than the 10 megapix sensor inside of the
s24 ultra and across all the photos
we've taken you can see better quality
and detail with the Oppo because of that
huge sensor and the higher resolution
especially when in low light or for
portrait photography and then finally we
have the 6X Periscope zoom on the Oppo
versus 5 on the s24 ultra and I've got
to say that the 100 35 mm focal length
looks great you can zoom really really
far up to
120x on the Oppo compared to 100 on the
s24 which by the way both of those are
way too far for my liking so comparing
at let's say
25x that's really nice for seeing things
very far away while still getting decent
quality and they both look pretty
similar between the two now on top of
all of that I do want to mention that
the ople find X7 Ultra does have their
hypertone image engine which gives you
great quality photos that look a lot
more natural and not overprocessed and
over HDR like you find on a lot of other
smartphone cameras they also have their
Hasselblad portrait mode which comes
with really nice and natural looking
bokeh compared to other brands that look
really fake and it also works up to 9 M
away which is really impressive and to
my surprise you can even shoot portrait
photos using the 6x lens which gives a
really nice DSLR Pro Camera feel to them
and Oppo also has their Master mode
which gives you full control over camera
details like the shutter speed the iso
white balance and more sort of like the
pro camera mode on the s24 ultra and
because of that Hasselblad camera you're
going to get the professional looking
characteristics of the Hasselblad medium
format camera so there you guys go those
were all of the differences compared and
I've got to say that if you want to
really unique phone this thing really
hits the spot especially with the design
with the white gloss that vegan leather
that feels really nice and especially
the display that matches up to what you
get on the s24 ultra the speakers that
are basically just as good and the
cameras that are incredibly impressive
and in some ways beating out what you
get in the s24 ultra I've got to say I'm
really impressed with the Oppo so if you
enjoy this video let me know your
thoughts down the comment section below
and definitely subscribe by clicking
that button above thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video